vu sur toll et qu'elle me plat une
situation désormais insupportable pour
les commerçants de la rue antoine siger
au centre ville de fort-de-france la rue
longe le grand marché couvert fermé pour
travaux depuis plusieurs mois dans ce
commerce on nous avoue avoir perdu 40 %
de chiffre d'affaires en cinq ans et
depuis le droit de retrait des
chauffeurs cft eu et l'arrêt complet du
transport public
le magasin ne fait plus que 200 à 300
euros par jour contre mille en moyenne
100 bus pas client pas de marché pas
touristes on est là on attend
moi j'aurais bien aimé que quelqu'un que
ce soit un chauffeur des mosaïques ou un
élu viennent pendant neuf heures ici
regarder la feuille de tôle et que la
feuille de tôle leurs gardes qui me
disent à la fin de la journée s'il est
satisfait ou pas satisfaits
moi je veux voir des clients j'ai besoin
de manger j'ai besoin de payer mes
dettes
j'ai besoin de faire bouger enfin il ya
une famille derrière
à six semaines du réveillon de noël
c'est un vrai coup dur pour les
commerçants car ils réalisent durant
cette période une grande partie de leur
chiffre d'affaires annuel
la vendeuse du magasin se souvient
encore de la belle époque
depuis 8h du matin avait déjà foule ici
mais vraiment foule jusqu'à 17 et
attrapes y avait du monde depuis sept
ans ça aide vraiment vraiment vraiment
diminué mohamed et son père ont lancé
une pétition signée par 28 des 30
commerçants de la rue il demande qu'elle
soit transformée en rue piétonne
jusqu'au faîte pour créer de l'animation
sans transports publics
ça n'est pas seulement la rue antoine
siger qui souffrent c'est tout le centre
ville déjà l'annnonce du droit de
retrait samedi dernier avait étonné les
commerçants tout en pleine action les
fouilles à lui donc surprise
réalisé qu'il y avait une grève qui
était été lancé le même jour tcsp les
bus permettent aux gens d'accéder sur la
ville et ses dires la ville
c'est vrai qu'on a souffert de cela
aujourd'hui encore donc la grève du lait
les personnes un peu plus manière fort
de france
j'ai même ici d un foyer qui vous à
venir mais qui n'ont pas de voiture des
petits jeux de stage et à qui voudraient
venir que d'une voiture qui ne peuvent
pas venir le 22 décembre prochain tout
le centre ville sera uniquement réservé
aux piétons
tout comme samedi dernier en espérant
que le public pourra s'y rendre nombreux
cette fois grâce notamment aux bus et au
tcsp